what your little bumpy on your lip a
bumpy yeah baby
no I don't yeah like a thing were you
eating pastor that a bumper might you me
not herpes sore neither be you do you
have a sword oh I know what that is I
was doing pull-ups at you know I trained
it Higa Machado's oh that's right
8 1 2 6 8 1 2 6 Wilshire Boulevard
Beverly Hills if you ever need me that's
why I train now listen to through your
flying talent that's what you find me I
was doing I was doing take that Grieco
takedowns I'm so ready
I can't give me a little more time sure
you won't tell me what don't be to take
back for all the time don't be
disrespectful because when I when I
represent my sensei Higa Machado yep
Allen if you want to make love you could
judge it you come on down bro but do me
a favor you come down to 8 1 2 6
Wilshire Boulevard
ok you come correct right I'm coming
correct cuz I respect the hell out of
him yeah come correct in front of them I
need a little more time I'm gonna pin
you down now all your pants I'm for any
instructor know what yeah I need more
time
piss on no I don't want to get [ __ ]
drunk I'm gonna piss on your friend cuz
oh no dude cuz what are you gonna do
oh how what do you do knee on belly no
it's gonna pin you down by your neck
brace oh dude don't [ __ ] the ring so
it's not popular Society got a rape joke
but you don't hold me like I want a
silver just like this your neck your
stupid little chicken neck no I don't
have a chicken I get out this big every
hack in this golden shower time huh no
I'm gonna see what your instructor
series getting you free lessons after
that no more no peeing on the mat sir no
piss on the no piss pissing on the mat
technology where they can take your
ak-47 your ar-15 they have drones and
everything else so the US army they can
shoot you from where you can't see the
helicopter you can't see the hell okay
boomer pretty good
hey I know about military [ __ ] okay I
don't like your saying I'm just saying
cuz you're gonna make me your new
training boomer but I've been doing
boom boom boom boom I'm gonna embarrass
you in front of your sensei he's gonna
see this you're not going to get a black
belt next week what's the problem you
two on one dude boom boom sit down no
boomer now what's this
don't make me roll out now huh so make
me roll out and [ __ ] up the studio
well this heel hook boomer boomer sit
down
okay okay boomer two on one is he
teaching you two on one on the back too
yeah did I if we don't worry about what
he's teaching me teach me [ __ ] where I'm
very complex due to I'm well on that
back I can still choke I'm very
comfortable I go two on one let's see
buddy told you ready not yeah you're too
strong so no just no - what do you mean
both cuz there's teach you to fight one
hand yeah boomer since they should be
this yeah we gotta teach you that boomer
stop learning go like what I don't know
right now that si boomer I'm not doing
anything
no you're gonna do something then I will
see what you're learning go
okay okay okay it's six to one mostly
[Laughter]
free
that's good okay man that's good it's
good
let's get stuff know how we get good
it's good roll it's good roll
I'll [ __ ] my defense is getting there
dude
pretty good I don't like that roll it's
not fun on my throat let's take those
tasty areas throw huh tasty here
juicy yeah you don't have a problem
killing man huh not you if you wanted
you could defend right no I mean I could
if I we were going crazy if we come to
the mat I'm not gonna go again
come to Matt listen Matt 861 what I
gotta do here and I use all my [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]